marvel studios eternals is a big movie
with big heroes an epic storyline and
cinematography screaming to be seen in
imax
as such it's easy to lose track of the
film's smaller characters here are some
eternals characters who mean more than
you realize that's cool
remember when scarlett johansson
appeared in iron man 2 it was noteworthy
for sure because joe handsome was
already a big star with films like lost
in translation and would-be blockbusters
like the island under her belt but her
first appearance as natasha romanov felt
like the character was intended to be a
scene-stealing sidekick not someone
who'd go on to become a top mcu
character and get her own spin-off movie
there's reason to believe that kit
harrington's dane whitman could be said
for a similar ascension in this newest
mcu phase in eternals it's almost
laughable how non-heroic he is existing
for two apparent reasons to ask the
questions fans want answered and to be a
supportive boyfriend
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
as cersei reveals to dane that she is a
god-like being has been on earth for 7
000 years and has an ex-boyfriend who
could disintegrate him with the blink of
an eye dane just makes gugu wise and
takes her for long romantic walks
how long were you together five thousand
years i guess you can go that long
which feels a little beneath the game of
thrones actor who just finished playing
jon snow lord commander of the night's
watch king in the north lord of the
seven kingdoms and protector of the
realm now kirch harrington is just a
boyfriend perhaps his apparent
insignificance is because in scenes we
never witness he is indeed on his own
hero's journey throughout the film near
the end of the film dane tells her see
his family history is complicated and
does any marvel fan with a smartphone
and a search engine can tell you dane
whitman will one day become a hero
called black knight of course the most
obvious reveal that kit harrington will
soon be wielding the legendary ebony
blade sword and riding on horseback is
the second post-credits scene we see
dane addressing a family legacy that
stretches back to the days of king
arthur examining the ebony blade he
delivers the ominous phrase death is my
reward before an off-camera voice
interrupts him with are you sure you're
ready for them rumor has it that dane's
story will be continued in 2022's doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness in
the comics the black knight not only
becomes an avenger but is known for his
ability to navigate different time
periods and alternate realities taking
all this into account you can see how
harrington's character could become
instrumental over the next several
marvel films
on the surface kingo's valet
filmographer feels like a walking punch
line every time kingo does something
heroic karoon is there to assure the
eternal that he got the shot every time
someone smashes his camera karoon
hilaricy seems to whip out another one
bingo
vista i've directed some things too but
look closer and you'll see the one human
that the eternals have come to trust
more than they ever have before over
thousands of years granted it's not like
they have much choice kingo insists that
his valet come along for the reunion but
over time they begin warming to the man
behind the camera when the smoke clears
karoon possesses not only the friendship
and trust of the eternals but an
incredibly valuable assemblage of raw
footage imagine being in possession of
film footage that would immediately
render all theology religion and world
history are relevant what will karun do
with this footage what is he willing to
do with it and would he do anything
without kingo's approval by the end of
the film the world likely knows that
some major events have occurred but it's
debatable whether the eternals have
revealed themselves it seems that as
their story moves along in the mcu their
existence will become common knowledge
don't be surprised if all that seemingly
comic relief footage shot by karoon is
what drags them into the spotlight
while the turtles breaks multiple
boundaries within the marvel cinematic
universe it treats most of these exactly
the way they should be treated as normal
everyday life one of these is a
relationship between faustos and his
husband ben who the other eternals learn
had been building a life together in
chicago with their adorable son jack
that's superman with the cape and you're
shooting laser beams out of your eyes
i don't wear a cape
this is the first time a same-sex couple
has been featured in a marvel studios
film their kiss as fastos is heading off
to save the world is not only a powerful
moment but a significant one for the
lgbtq community considering how many
millions of people all over the globe
watch every marvel film it also means a
great deal personally to actor har
slayman who came out as gay in 2017 the
actor explained to variety at the film's
premiere beyond the dream come true it's
life-saving i wish i had that
representation when i was a kid my god i
wish can you imagine how many lives this
is going to be saving kids young queer
folk who are being bullied and now they
get to see this it's above and beyond
according to writer director chloe zhao
marvel had already laid out a blueprint
for the family of fastos when she came
on board finding true love after
thousands of years returns of faith in
humanity to fastos and leads to his
personal decision to not only fight for
humans but eventually return to them so
on one level ben might feel just like
another supportive spouse character in
the mcu no different than hawkeye's wife
laura on another level that might make
him one of the most important characters
we've ever seen in the mcu
sprite is among the very first eternals
debuting in 1976's eternals issue 9 but
in the comics she is typically a he who
inspired both shakespeare who created
the character perk in his image and j m
barry who did the same with peter pan
because eternals features 10 main heroes
there isn't a lot of time for deep dives
into these characters as such sprite
feels like one of the eternals that gets
short shrift in the comics bright is
much more fully realized and employs
illusions much more frequently every bit
as mischievous as loki sprites also
possesses mata manipulating abilities
similar to cersei and is strong enough
to lift several tons in eternals sprite
is compared to the peter pan story not
as its inspiration but because the way
she secretly yearns to be with icarus is
reminiscent of how tinkerbell could
never be with the boy who wouldn't grow
up ultimately however the mcu sprite
feels more like pinocchio who yearns to
be real in eternals volume 5 issue 1
released just a few months before the
movie was released it was revealed that
the eternal switch gender every few
thousand years this is never mentioned
in the movie but the fan favorite
character is depicted as being female
when she first appears on earth as well
as thousands of years later in the
modern age
another eternal who gets the reader's
digest treatment in the future film is
gilgamesh another comic character whose
history with the title stretches back to
the mid-70s that history has
intermingled with hercules achilles
buffalo bill and king david and for a
time he even fought for the roman empire
perhaps it is appropriate in a way that
he seems to receive the least screen
time of any of the eternals in the pages
of marvel comics he was punished for
many years after learning about the true
nature of his heritage confined to
olympia he was branded the forgotten one
and was subsequently ostracized for
centuries in the movie gilgamesh is a
chef that enjoys preparing bountiful
feasts and has also taken on the
personal task of becoming a caretaker
for fina he also wields a big powerful
punch which feels a bit redundant after
marvel audiences have already seen
several other characters who can do
essentially the same thing in the film
each eternal is depicted as having their
own unique power in the comics gilgamesh
who join the avengers for a brief period
also has superhuman speed can shoot
beams of cosmic energy and can use his
telekinetic power to take flight which
is all very impressive but perhaps not
nearly as much as a meal he makes for
the eternals in australia
this is really good girl
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
eternals are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]